hello everybody and welcome to the third
Python and pandas basics tutorial video
in our video series in this video we're
gonna be actually coding finally sorry
for anybody who was getting impatient
and what we're gonna do in this video is
talk about how to write to a CSV file
and how to pull from a CSV file
now to do this we're actually going to
we don't have a data set so we're gonna
have to conjure up a data set so we're
gonna use yahoo finance to pull some
finance data so we can create a CSV file
with some data that everybody can access
and then also pull from that CSV so
probably one of the most common
operations and one of my most popular
videos is saving data to a CSV and
reading from a CSV and then later on
graphing that data and stuff like that
and you can do this in pure Python but
it's very simple in pandas and so it's
good to know how to do it in pandas I'm
still a pretty big advocate for knowing
how to code everything yourself but once
you understand how to do some of these
things yourself it's good to use
something like pandas because pandas is
gonna speed it up for you
and pandas is gonna do it a much more
efficient manner than you but as time
goes on you're gonna find yourself
having some problems with pandas or
maybe there's something in penis that
you don't know how to do or because of
the structure of pandas it's literally
impossible to do with pandas it's good
to know how to do things yourself as
well but anyway enough on that let's get
started so the first thing that we're
gonna want to do is we need to imports
that we're gonna be meeting with pandas
so to read or to save to a CSV and from
a CSV you're gonna need a couple of
things one you're gonna want to import
pandas as PD that's just the way people
import pandas often it's just PD just
like numpy as NP so import pandas SPD so
we can use pandas and then another thing
that we're gonna want is from pandas
import data frame and the data set that
we're gonna get is gonna be a two
dimensional array and it's going to be
much like an umpire right like I said
but then we can also treat it
like a dictionary just so everyone's
comfy with what we're doing so so we
have those two things so to write to a
CSV and read from a CSV that's literally
all you need but we also want to
communicate with Yahoo Finance so we're
going to need a couple of things for
that so first we're gonna import date
time and this is so we can specify a
slice of data that we want from Yahoo
Finance because Yahoo Finance has it's a
very specific date stamp now just just
to clarify when if when we later go to
graph data like this we actually don't
need date/time so if you were gonna do
it by hand yourself you wouldn't need a
time to convert into the time stamp but
actually you won't need date/time like
date/time is actually I think pandas
uses day time but you won't need to
touch date/time at all anyway moving on
also we're going to import pandas dot IO
dot data and this is again this is just
so we can import data from Yahoo Finance
I just want to stress what's required
for reading and writing the CSV use and
what's not so now we can say SP 500
equals PDI Oh data dot get underscore
data underscore Yahoo data what day do
we want to get we'll just grab SP 500
data so that's five eg SPC is the ticker
name for hit a comma enter now we can
say start equals date time dot date time
and this is really the only reason why
we needed it's the only reason why we
needed date time it's just so we can
feed a date time object through for
Yahoo Finance so it knows what we're
looking for
anyway 2010 and one so that'll start
October 1st 2000 and then outside of
this we're gonna say N equals date time
date time and then here we'll say 2014
today is 611 so do that and that's it so
that is gonna read the data in S&P 500
so what we could do is first let's go
ahead and print S&P 500 just so we can
see what we're working with so we'll run
this and here is the output from the S&P
500 in for information so you have date
open high low close volume and adjusted
close and you can see that date is kind
of like down a little bit here and
that's because date is the index and
these are not indexes but they are like
titles labels rather not titles
anyway scrolling down to the bottom here
because it acts like an umpire array it
does what we expect an umpire ready to
do and kind of it's not gonna print out
the entire thing if we come down here we
can see that we have three thousand four
hundred and forty two rows times six
columns worth of data so we have this
data set now we want to save it to a CSV
so if we just naturally save this to a
CSV it wouldn't be separate it wouldn't
be delimited for us but what we can do
instead is we can close out of this and
we can stop printing it oh one quick
thing we can print S&P 500 like we just
did but that printed a lot of data right
more than we would need and more than we
can use right so when you print out SNP
500 it prints out quite a bit of data
but you would never need that much right
if you wanted to see the whole data set
you would you know maybe save it to a
file and look at it or you would specify
exactly what you wanted it to print out
but in most cases you're actually
looking for just to see if you like the
structure and so to do that you can
actually use dot head and this just
prints like the first bit of information
so we can save and run that real quick
and now it only gives us just five rows
real quick just so we can see the
structure of the data and we don't hide
it's a lot less memory intensive and
there's no reason to print as many roses
we did before so just show you guys real
quick that dot head command now to save
to CSV we can do the following sp500 dot
to underscore CSV and then we specify
the CSP name that we want we'll call
this sp500 underscore ohlc dot CSV done
there's no you know rye and then dot
right and then oh don't forget to close
that just save run it and it's done and
let's see I'll pull it up for you guys
no pad here it is done very simple we've
got the first you know label row and
then all of the data so we just pulled
all of this data from Yahoo Finance and
indeed we have over 3,000 rows almost
3.5 thousand rows of data pulled so that
was great so now we can close out of
this and so that is to CSV
we've saved to CSV now we don't need any
of this code anymore so I'm just
literally gonna comment all of this out
because now we have a CSV file and now
we want to read from that CSV again
super simple to do this so we're gonna
say DF for data frame equals P D dot
read underscore CSV you can call this a
series but it's not series right because
it's a two dimensional array so this is
going to be a data frame pain is just
gonna automatically know and that's how
it's gonna save it but anyway read CSV
what CSV is that well the same one that
we just saved so I'm just gonna copy and
paste it so read CSV here you could just
get away with just this so let me show
you what happens when I print DF let's
print gift out head and so save and run
that and here you have this okay and you
see how it it gave us like this you know
the primary here whatever worth of data
that's kind of annoying but we didn't
specify any index or anything like that
so what we can do instead is we can pull
this over here and when we read from the
CSV let me close out of that when we
read from the CSV we can say index
underscore call call call equals and
then specify the date so capital dat
that was the title of the column and
then also we can just let it know hey
there are dates here so parse dates
equals true now save that run it and
we'll pull this over and now we can see
indeed date is now our our index here
and then we have open high low close
volume adjusted close so now we have all
that data we have it basically the same
way that we just read it from Yahoo
Finance now it just automatically read
it into a data frame and just
automatically knew that it was a data
frame and to give the index value to
dates
whereas reading from a CSV is a lot
different you're gonna want to specify
hey this is the indexes date and also it
has dates you can just notify it hey
parse the dates and it is gonna
intuitively parse the dates so later on
I can show you guys what we can do with
that and why that becomes very useful
but anyway that's going to conclude this
video just how to write to a CSV how to
read from a CSV extremely simple
literally just read CSV or to CSV simple
as that and very quick very intuitive
and also just whenever you're doing this
even if this CSV file is a massive file
it's very good at what it does it's very
efficient so definitely a good method
for reading and writing csps so anyways
that's gonna conclude this video if you
guys have any questions or comments feel
free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and it's a
nice time